twentieth Century Fox has dropped the
third official trailer for the upcoming
Deadpool sequel which is now officially
titled Deadpool to the not-safe-for-work
trailer sees the Merc with a mouth at
his absolute mouth is as he meets up
with old friends and puts together a
whole new crew for his new adventure
it's a lot to take in to take a breath
and follow along as we serve up all the
small details you miss in the trailer
for Deadpool to protect your neck or the
early teasers for Deadpool - were cute
this third trailer finally brings all
the goods it also offers the first
glimpse of the movie story in the comics
the time-traveling Cable spent a lot of
his time protecting his adopted daughter
hope and Deadpool - appears to have the
mutant traveling through time to save a
mysterious mutant child from captivity
it appears that Deadpool end up captured
at some point in the movie judging by
the gloving red collar which doesn't
seem to be there just for the sake of
kink it also looks like the same type of
colour that mutant kid is wearing in one
scene the trailer initially positions
cable and Deadpool as enemies with both
heroes adopting a punch first ask
questions later approach could Deadpool
end up in the custody of the same people
holding cables target captive sick kicks
the original dev bore was a relatively
lean affair but after its massive and
unprecedented success Volks has let the
money fly from the looks of things it's
all ended up on screen the trailer shows
off action sequences and numerous
locations proving that Deadpool is
definitely getting around this time
there's also a blink in you're missing
shots of Deadpool than a fight at a
strip club doing a front flip and
sticking the landing and a pair of
high-heeled boots they sort of look like
a dominatrix is custom ordered pair of
Louboutins which would make sense we're
not exactly sure why it makes sense but
for Deadpool it totally does New Mutants
a big chunk of the new Deadpool trailer
is spent showing off the new mutants of
the x-force
but one thing the trailer doesn't serve
up so readily is the identities of all
these obscure x-force members the new
trailer makes it clear that Terry Crews
will be portraying bedlam a mutant with
the power to send EMP blasts in the
comics Domino teamed up with bedlam to
help him find his brother but who's the
new kid the teddy bear cable carries
suggests a caretaker mission and the
teaser for the movie from a year ago
contains graffiti Easter eggs referring
to Nathan summers and hope now that the
full trailer has arrived
it suggests that cable is out to protect
this kid played by the new zealand-born
actor
Julian Dennison I'm here for the kid the
kid for now it seems likely that
Dennison is playing the obscure mutant
Thunderbird aka Neil Shara but really
where's hope the trailer also gives a
glimpse at she ally could sooner as a
mutant with electrical powers and
distinctive hair our money for this role
is on search
aka Noriko Ishida who originally
appeared in the comic book series New
Mutants in 2004 the value of a metal man
the Deadpool 2 trailer also features a
return to Xavier school for gifted
youngsters while most fans caught the
glimpse of Colossus the real joke is in
the background with a framed portrait of
Cole Marx placed by one of the school
staircases
it looks like Xavier is teaching his
students how to harness their powers and
seize the means of production of course
the trailer also features an instant
classic shot of Deadpool commandeering
professor X's wheelchair it's chapter
1.5 we already knew all about za z beats
taking on the role of Domino as part of
Deadpool and cables x-force but we had
no idea that penny wise was hiding out
on set the full Deadpool 2 trailer
features our best look yet - actor Bill
skarsgård has an unnamed member of the X
force some guesses have him being pegged
as rector a mutant had once had a
serious grudge against cable due to
believing the time traveler killed his
father
additionally Richter is in a
relationship with the mutant shatta star
a sword-wielding mutant who can be seen
standing behind their Paul in one-shot
couching a socially progressive message
in a movie full of four-letter words and
the cavitations is exactly the sort of
thing that Paul would do purity Sh
Moretti well the trailer doesn't get too
into details in the movies antagonists
it does it like a group of bad guys are
set on keeping humans and mutants
segregated you can see Domino delivering
the beatdown to an enemy in a room
wallpapered with propaganda posters with
slogans like purity humanity infinity on
the walls whatever the bad guys are up
to exactly we wouldn't be surprised if
it was the start of something bigger
after all x-force is going to need some
kind of cause to fight and human mutants
Epirus sounds like just a ticket
we'll call you at some point cable and
Deadpool team up to try and put a team
together and what better way than
headshots and auditions Deadpool pages
through the resumes of a whole gaggle of
mutant mercenary hopefuls with the
trailer pausing pointedly on a photo of
one
to lanius pizza whoo Delaney is a
comedian best known for super popular
Twitter accounts and the television
series catastrophe whether or not
Delaney will actually play a part in the
movie we're not quite sure he could be
Pete wisdom another occasional ally of
the x-men who can throw energy blades
from its fingers in the comics Pete
helps bedlam hone his powers and teaches
in martial arts we know one thing for
sure though we definitely want to see
the rest of those head shots this
iteration of the x-force is off-the-wall
enough already
the rejected pile for this project must
really be something else thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're lifting
[Music]